do you think the NFL is making a mistake
by bringing her back and trying to make
it safer for the quarterback I think you
got to be careful you don't let him play
football out of football I learned a
long time ago if you want to it really
like to lose you lose I don't like to
lose today I think it was the greatest
quarterback of all time
Kaepernick Neal's say you're his coach
what should have the coaches and the
team done from the 49ers standpoint are
you mad at the country we met it's a
flag who tell you're mad at that's all
just tell me who you're mad at so today
I'm sitting with the person here that
won Super Bowl as a player Super Bowl as
a assistant coach Super Bowl as a coach
and the only one to have scored as a
player in the Super I know Tom Flores
also did it on those three categories
but you're the only one that scored a
touchdown in Super Bowl and that's one
of it none other than Mike Ditka so Mike
coach Ditka thank you so much for making
the time for coming with us
so there you go that's your resume on
what you've done I am fascinated by your
competitive spirit and when I read about
you and I hear the stories with your
father Pittsburgh all this other stuff I
kind of want to go back and ask you a
simple question of who was Mike Ditka
before coach Ditka who was Mike that gun
high school 12 years old or left I guess
eighth grade what is that and and I
played on a I went to a Catholic grade
school so I play that we had a little
football team and I played there and
worse the next year I went the 9th grade
at the big high school and I went out
for football I got killed
yeah I don't know I'm not here anymore
cuz I get killed you know and I like
football but I was a pretty good
baseball player so the next year I yeah
I went out again as a sophomore I think
I killed more cuz I only weighed 130
pounds so yeah we're not good oh no I
was small and then between my sophomore
junior in high school I grew to about
511 and I went up to 165 70 power and I
started on the state championship
football team and not because I was a
great player because I had a great coach
who believed in me and took me aside and
taught me how to do the things I had to
do to become a good team player and I
played offense and defense and that's
the way it was well I mean I was I
played both ways in college
most of what I did was on defense not
offense most of what you did in college
was on as defense even I cut think my
senior year I think I caught like 15
passes but I played defensive end and
linebacker that's where I got all the
notoriety and when I went into pro ball
anybody that drafted me outside of the
Bears I probably would have been a
linebacker
Georgiy really in George Halas when when
I when he drafted me I went and talked
to him and he said and I saw much
playing defense I really did and he said
we're gonna we're going to create the
position of tight end and you're gonna
play tight end I said coach I see it my
senior year in college I got 1216 passes
some you know comes crazy
he said we're to work out we're gonna be
ok and it was I had two good coaches and
coach Alice and a couple other guys they
were old school but they taught these
the basics you know football is basics
you know tackling it's blocking its
execution and they taught me the thing
called blocking you know what's allowed
hold somebody so I know you said your
first year when he came out the year
before he said 12 or 15 catches well
your first year in the NFL you had 58
with 12 touchdowns yes this guy was
crazy yeah it was unheard of what was
tightened a comment you know philosophy
position back then for coaches or not
really know that it was it really was
created right around that time there
were a couple in the leg I can't John
Mackey came in the year after me
Ron Kramer was up in Green Bay there
were a couple guys a couple guys out of
Sanford a quarterback named Bill way God
rest his soul
he just liked the throws of football to
me because I caught it and after I
caught it I would have fun running with
it
so he he making me I didn't make me me
after that we won the championship in 63
and 64 we lost two guys in a car
accident down in training camp two great
football players and so Johnny Morris
and I had
were the leading receivers on the team
in 1964 after the 63 season between us
he caught 98 balls and I caught like 70
and in that time was unheard of but we
weren't a good team we were not a good
team now that year after that we became
a good team because we got a guy named
Joe Gayle sayers was kind of a good yeah
human botches we got him in buckets the
next year and moved him a real good
football game so and we didn't win it a
year Baltimore beat Assad by one game
but we were really a good team of 65 so
going back what did your work ethic come
from your work ethic your discipline
your mind says there no we never we were
never given anything or expecting
anything you know so Auerbach fact I
remember I had to have a paper route
when I came home whatever I made on
paper route ideas and my parents they
gave me an allowance I never had you
know that's what it was even when I was
in high school I had a job working for
the borough or for the swimming pool
lifeguard and I gave a check to my
parents they gave me allowance that's
the way it was I mean that's the way I
was raised and this is Pittsburgh yeah
I'll equip my steel mill town right
outside of Pittsburgh in the heyday jnow
still employed 35,000 people but now it
might might employ 3,500 maybe but the
work ethic was fantastic get up go to
work take your lunch bucket that was the
way we live that's where all the did you
watch your dad did you watch your family
work hard or was it a conversation was
it like when was your dad coming home
every night was your five day a week I
was my dad's dad had a routine he went
to work he left the house probably right
before 7:00 he probably got home about
5:00 but the reasoning woman 5 he could
have got home at 4:00 but he stopped
they all stopped at the tavern see it
have there four or five beers and that's
then he come home dinner had to be ready
he was dinner and when he get cleaned up
probably go back to the camera that's
what they that's all they did
but I could do to you one thing he was
self-taught he can work any crossword
puzzle you put in front of Hugh work now
that's pretty bad
had an eighth-grade education it was
good my dad's the same eighth grade
education competitive spirit is that in
your blood or is that was the family
saying hey Mike how fast you're gonna
run who's better than you who's that was
there that conversation or was it just
you your DNA I learned a long time ago
if you want to if you like to lose you
lose I didn't like to lose it anything
probably that was wrong as a kid growing
up in the Little League baseball in that
but I didn't like to lose anything I
wanted to win what's wrong with that why
do you sit but maybe it was wrong what's
what's I think anytime you compete you
compete with the idea of you're trying
to win now you may not then if you don't
win you got to be a good sport about it
but when I was growing up I think the
winning team became and we became
obsessed with it I mean really and I was
fortunate to I've played on a good high
school football team that won a state
championship and it wasn't it was
because of the coach widow and the
players we had but it was fun growing up
there I mean now you know nobody nobody
had any more than you were less than you
really all about the same I mean all our
parents worked in the mill or my dad
works on the railroads it serviced the
mill but that's not we had that I mean
nobody had any more than anybody else
but it was okay we did good do you think
a part of competition is within the
individual or you think do you think
that's created I think you have to have
machines for there's no question about
it I really do you're right everybody
can come from st. Pierre or same parents
and when one person will be super
competitive I don't say they'll go with
the flow I guess that was one of the
super comparisons and I wanted that I
wanted to try harder I mean I and I had
to when I was young because I was a
smaller guy and I was but then as I got
bigger
you know things got better for me but I
can still think back to you know nine
ten years old playing baseball how
competitive I was that how much I loved
it when I first started playing baseball
little leg was played in my that's how
long it was played it just started it
just started it so I played a little
league baseball and you were super
competitive at that time yeah so coming
up to the next level you're playing in
high school you're at 130 pounds and you
go five 1165 pounds so now you got some
size you're playing to three sports with
there other kids you played with we said
that guy's way more talented than me
faster than me stronger than me but
there's no way in the world that guy can
outwork me
or out-compete me word there guys like
that at every face that you went through
about 20 or 30 of my faves yeah and I
think you make a good point
the attitude the individual has to work
at it I mean you know you can't get
better by doing nothing you know if you
want to be a better hitter you better
learn a hit you know if you want to be a
better fielder or field same with
football you know you got to strengthen
the body and I don't care how you do it
whether you're lift weights or you do it
through conditioning but you you know
you your body can only take so much I
mean football today the players are
bigger they're faster and they're
stronger than when I played the game so
when you have a collision football now
it's much greater than what we had and
ours are pretty good but it's much
greater so you know we get to you know
in the law of physics you got two bodies
moving on a high rate of speed
something's gonna give how do you fix
that I don't think you can I think
people are bigger faster stronger like I
said and the game is the risk of injury
is much greater probably even today than
it was 30 years ago because the guys are
just I mean they're better athletes but
by being that you're moving the higher
rate of speed and the collisions are
like greater so what do you dummy you
know do have you know the whole CT I
never had a quarterback McMahon that he
wouldn't know you know yeah his own
issues and you've seen it all the time
would say oh and all these other stories
because to me this is how I look at it
so you have boxing you had Tyson Evander
you know Riddick ball these guys have
come along and then it was kind of
trying to protect the players and all
these things protect the fighters and
then Dana White comes out and says hey
how about UFC MMA
there is no pretending there is some
protection like you can't need a guy on
the ground and drop your knee on his
face you do that you're gonna get a loss
but they're going all out I know do you
think the NFL is making a mistake by
bringing her back and trying to make it
safer for the quarterbacks you see what
happened with Green Bay you know the guy
gets three sacks he gets each game he
gets a flag for each one of them and
each of them look pretty good well I
think the antenna is right I mean you're
always trying to protect the player from
injury but how do you do it what do you
do you tell player who's rushing here
here's his whole key he's on defense his
job is to go get the quarterback so all
of a sudden when you go to get the
quarterback
you're you're moving a high rate of
speed what do you how do you change that
Sam no I understand how driving the guy
but it's a natural thing once you wrap a
guy up you take him to the ground I mean
I watched the penalty on and the kid
from Green Bay and I disagree with it
totally because I don't think he was out
to hurt anybody
he was taking the guy to the ground
naturally when you take a guy to the
ground his buddies usually underneath
yours
you fall on top of them I I don't know
how you can check I think you got to be
careful you don't legislate football out
of football I mean it's a contact sport
I mean it's more than contact where it's
a collision sport it is what it is I
mean I didn't make the rules
I played the game for a long time
wouldn't change you for anything but you
got to be careful that you know he said
well does it make it a better game does
it make it any safer I don't know if it
does if NFL wonders face and say look
our concern is making everything safe so
why don't we go from contact to flag do
you think they would lose viewership
they wouldn't have leadership if they
want purely from contact flag they would
lose viewership right would you watch I
would never want to so that's the point
it's a so the question becomes for you
do you think there's a outside chance
that another league that allows more
physicality can come and compete against
the NFL and get viewers kind of like
what UFC did to boxing I I don't know if
that that's possible right now the NFL
is the game is good I mean I understand
what the league's trying to do they're
trying to you know but the risk of
injury when you play the sport I'm sorry
it's there's like boxing if you don't
think you're gonna get whack when your
box or a boxer yeah and you you're
dreaming it's just part of it part of
the game but I can understand what
they're trying to do and keeping it as
safe as possible but you can't legislate
football out of football because there's
no longer football then you play tag
even Aaron Rodgers said you know I don't
think I like the direction it's going
he's a quarter I know
and he disagreed with the call he's a
quarterback insane hey the guy tackle
says he says this is an abandoned why
are you flagging him he's trying to
protect a lamech I thought it was pretty
interesting what he was doing well I
tell you what Aaron Rodgers his first
class I mean he's the best so you know I
would listen to him if I was a the link
I hope they do I hope they do because
viewership goes and then the business
goes you know did
interesting Parkers you're a coach you
you know as a fan we watch you on
sidelines you're not teaching hesitation
so I'm just thinking I'm a linebacker
I'm going to you in that thought I'm
hesitating you don't want me to hesitate
other than others react that's really
instantaneous react but this is making
me tensed yeah exactly and I think you
will make people hesitate but I mean it
in theory it will but once you're on the
field I don't know how you can hesitate
you have to fire the gun and that's what
they do
yeah sometimes too much regulation just
like it hurts business too much
regulation hurts sports as well and it's
I don't know the answer to the question
I'm asking what I'm trying to say I
agree in idea of preventing injuries if
you can prevent a plan but there's no
guarantee you can the game is just it's
a physical game these are big bodies
colliding at a high rate of speed and
usually someone's got a game yeah I
agree
so a coaching career coach I mean you
dealt with a lot of different
personalities you dealt with you know
the owner
Halas who you know gave you $18,000 and
next he wanted to give you a raise to
$14,000 he know like what it it wasn't
quite that way but it was close
you know but I don't I wouldn't change
any of that I mean at the time I never
understood it but it was a learning
process you know you know you tell
somebody at my first year contract was a
$12,000 but you know in those days this
was 1961 so I got it and I got it and I
got a bonus a signing bonus of 6,000 now
twelve and six is 18 now I can I can
figure that out I'm not a genius so
after the year I made rookie the year
and all throwin so I went in to have a
contractor and we everything was face to
face with mr. Harris and I said you know
and he said you know kid you had pretty
good year listen and then he pulls out
this [ __ ] but you know you miss curfew
and had a finding for this or that and
he's right I did but any finally for but
he says but I'm still gonna give you a
raise he said we'll pay you 14 I say
coach or something matter with a knee so
what do you mean I said I made 12 and
then six that that's 18 I said now you
wanna pay me 14 years cut my salary
I said I wouldn't sign for a penny less
than 18 as soon as I said that he opened
the door pulled out a contract for
18,000 then I signed it and you know you
say I wasn't gonna I wasn't gonna get
ahead of him
I mean I thought it was smart I thought
well I showed him yeah I really showed
him I'm making the same thing at me last
year but so what it was worth it I
wouldn't change it for anything and the
question I wanted to ask you is
personality-wise because you got a
strong personality right like you know
what you want you're confident you come
in good well yeah you obviously made it
to the top level in multiple different
positions but for yourself what did you
learn like I'm a CEO I run a financial
from a lot of different people I deal
with personality-wise entrepreneurs
watching this they run businesses sales
customers partners vendors all these
other things throughout the process of
coming up what did you learn on how to
deal with different personalities did
you finally come up with a clear
philosophy that worked for you when it
comes into working with other whatever
you said whatever the rules the
philosophy you set for your organization
or your company or your team it has to
apply to everybody it can't be different
it can't be one thing for Walter Payton
and the next thing for this guy the next
thing for that guy it has to be uniform
everybody has to abide by the rule you
have to stab the same goal and then you
know what we try to create neither
learners through coach Landry in Dallas
you try to create goals and then you try
to create methods to reach those goals
that were reasonable we're outstanding
whatever but if you say okay we want to
win the NFC East or West or sex or
whatever it is what do you got to do
well you know what you got to do you got
to come away with at least four wins
against Green Bay Minnesota and destroy
yeah you come out of that form too now
you got a better chance if you don't
you've probably got no chance at all I
mean and that doesn't guarantee you're
gonna get it I'm saying but you got to
control what you can control with that
sure division that doesn't mean you're
gonna win the NFL because it keeps
outside of your division are just as
good but it starts inside your division
and that's what we try to do we broke it
down that way the Bears we played Green
Bay in Detroit Minnesota we got we got
to come out of there for two at least
we're fortunate to know that we had good
years where we came out five one bad bad
years were we came out two and forth I
mean but who would tougher personalities
I mean you played
I mean you go through history's sayers
okay Gail okay so you got pay a Peyton
you got Perry you got you know owner
Hallas Landry buddy Ryan who was like
who was more difficult and more driven
than you that you were you like I'm the
most driven guy I know was there anybody
like this guy wants to win where I dunno
nobody nobody was wanted to achieve or
be better nobody you nobody be gained on
harder than you more know than water
Peyton nobody had to drive and the
initiative and desire to be the best
that Walter had Wow he what he was and
he was he really was a bit but people
don't know you don't even get to be the
best by you know say well he was he was
gifted with a good body and he wasn't
the fastest guy he wasn't the strongest
guy but pound per pound it probably was
but he worked hard at everything you
know he made himself who he was he made
a total commitment to being the best and
he I still think he was the best that
I've ever seen so was he the guy at the
locker room that made everybody calm did
he bring a mob was he poisoned a big
speaker he wasn't you know we had a lot
of guys on our defense and sure Hampton
and Singletary those guys who were a
little more vocal and I did speak up a
neighbor they got our team up but water
water was a great example of doing by
example and that's what he did he did it
by example and it was a good example and
anyone where started he started on the
practice field if you're the first one
out there the last one off that's what
he was and he worked as hard as anybody
now you're saying right why does he have
to do that I mean he's Walter Payton but
he didn't I don't know why it did he did
and you find the great ones they're like
that they might be in the batting cage a
little longer than the other guy you
read stories about him that's was some
story about he was doing this yeah he
was going on his legs and it's yeah it
really pound-for-pound I mean his
strength was amazing it really was his
strength strength he any work that but
most of what he did really was he ran
the hills just what I say some hills out
there and they need random and you know
you try to do that up and
now you talk about getting your knees
and your ankles and everything else in
shape you really do and I I couldn't
come down the stairs right now but I'm
just saying in the old days we did all
that stuff so Payton would be at the top
a guy that wanted a more than you were
in my in your opinion so you work with
begin different personalities helis
Landry up in Landry when you talk about
Landry you get emotional and curious you
know what it was with Landry when you
worked with him that he was different
because he brought you in at a time he
made the phone call he said yeah yeah
you were done and he gave you shot and
it kind of worked out so well how was it
working with Landry what was his
approach of leadership with you he was
the most organized guy I've ever been
around who was assisting you totally
totally organized and he had he had a
you know we we have to do this this this
and then and then really and he broke it
down and he made us believe that and if
we did those things good things came I
mean we we went through a lot of great
players in Dallas they drafted good and
they did a lot of good things but we
don't we had a lot of players that were
good players that didn't end up there
because he changed it he brought people
in that were going to be team player he
wanted the team he didn't care about
that you know you're gonna have some
stars I went Roger Staubach was a star
but he was a team star and you know and
the same thing with the other guys we
had playing at that time I mean we had
good running backs we had that I mean
nobody would know who that you know we
had two tight ends might say yourself
and another guy but you know it was just
a good good team and the defense was the
best part of it you know we had Bob
lilies and Leroy Jordans and those guys
and it was the best part of what the
Cowboys had but no matter when you play
a team sport like football you got it
one size got to complement the other and
if you have a great defense and the
great offense and your special team
stink you won't win anything so it's
everything you got to make everybody get
involved well the guy says well all I do
is I cover kicks and punches or your
better cover them as good as anybody in
the world and then that's what you tell
them and you know I've seen a lot of
great players start out by being guys
that cover on kickoffs and punts and
stuff like that they went on to become
great linebackers in the league was
Landry a guide his strength was it a
one-on-one strength was your locker room
store
was he a group strength like what was
land was he was totally organizing
everything but he did you know it was
more organized than anything I've ever
been around we had the meetings we had
long meetings but there was a purpose to
everything we did and he made it
understandable you know you can't get
better by saving me but you get better
you're gonna get better if you work on
this and this you know I can't tell you
that you know how much time he spent
well we call an angle block an angle
blocks were tight in you split this far
from your tackle you're blocking down on
the defensive end man those guys are
usually pretty good players but you
learn to do that I can't tell you how
much time we took with that with the
tackle and tackle maybe pull around gets
a linebacker you got an angle block the
end you do it enough you believe it you
can do it against anybody I mean I'm
about the greatest players in the league
and yeah Willie Davis whoever they were
great but you you have to do that's your
job he's my man I got a block I don't
care who it is what was Hal is his
strength like what was he good at was he
purely a business guy or did he dance or
something you picked up from him you got
to either understand what we're coach
when he he's one of the original four or
five guys that started the National
Football League so you know it was hard
for him to see the change you know he
know he had Red Grange I mean I think he
paid Red Grange probably the biggest
salary in football probably ever heard
up until I don't know what year would be
but you know you're talking about a game
that was it was just a game I mean and
then it became it's a multi-million
dollar business now it's a big big
business so he I don't know that he
would enjoy seeing the game the way it
is today maybe you'd enjoy this talent
but I don't know if he ever thought it
would ever get this big and I'm telling
you now he really yeah him and Rooney
and you know they were about five woman
I can't name them all now anymore guy up
in Green Bay but I mean they they all
started this whole thing and I think
they had a great idea but their vision
could have never been through what it's
been a tional football the guys ain't
I'm not it's big and it's big and it's
good and it's you know it's it provides
tremendous opportunities for
all people race color religion doesn't
matter you know you get you got an
opportunity so he was more division
there who was a true believer in what
he's doing absolutely it was a die-hard
fan of the game as well did he have to
love at the game or not really love the
game he loved me he was well liked
that's what I'm saying it's all the
Bears honor his all right god I mean
that's all I mean that was all he cared
about
I mean sure I mean he had he became a
successful man in business too but he
really cared about football that's
that's good NFL buddy Ryan how was bull
was Buddy Ryan strength buddy Ryan was a
great coach his strength was he did it
his way he he figured out a long time
ago if if he could bring more people
than you could block you were gonna have
a problem if he could bring more would
you like a purely blitz all the time so
what no what I yeah he blessed the line
there were we he played a defense called
the 54 defense people don't know what it
is you couldn't play it today because
what would happen if you play it say
they'd spread you out and they'd really
screw you up but everybody thought when
when you play buddy's defense you the
key thing was to protect which it was
you had to protect the quarterback so
they would bunch everybody up that's
what he wanted so the only way you could
do it was to spread them out now you
would know who was so know you didn't
put a linebacker cover a slot receiver
now you got the advantage but the ball
is gonna come out quick there's no
question about it
so buddy's really changing III think it
really changed the way offenses were
played because you people didn't no
longer bunch him up we found that out we
went down we played mile on me
then coach Shula and the first thing
they did they went to a three receiver
set on us and I think it was Nate Matt
Moore was in the slot then duck
we had a linebacker cover hello that
doesn't work so they beat us that night
the evolution of the game things changed
buddy's defense was fantastic if you
thought you had to keep everybody in a
rocket you couldn't you had to spread it
out now what you gonna go you're gonna
get mismatches and the coverage and
that's the only way you could you could
defend bid it go was that the conflict
that you guys were that was that is that
maybe we had no fault conflict that was
all over drawn I mean when buddy wanted
to go he thought he should have been the
head coach of the Bears from
I was hired that's no problemm I asked
you to sweeten you and him could have
coexisted for many years I could
coexisted yeah I could have built I
think he could have - yeah but I think
it was time he wante me didn't want to
be a head coach and I think he he wanted
to do things his way and and you know we
had an opportunity in Philadelphia you
know it's interesting last year I took
80 of our executives to New York and we
rented out the entire Oheka Castle it's
a nice place we rent out the entire
place 232 bedrooms and I had all our
guys sit there in a room and we watched
the 85 Bears together and we talked
about it for three hours because there's
so much to learn from that that season
there is so many different elements on
leadership on unifying on overcoming
personalities on overcoming challenges
understanding the bigger picture on
realizing somebody needs to rise up in
the locker room the flag carrier well
you know people don't understand the
football team as great as our defense
was our offense controlled the ball we
time a possession we led the league in
time who said we led the league in first
downs no you say well but that doesn't
and we led the league in scoring too but
that was a lot of that was because of
where the defense got us the football
there's no question about that but
you've got to compliment one with the
other and the same with special team if
you have a great defense or offense your
special teams think you got to get in
trouble you may not lose all the game
but you're gonna lose the majority I'm
coming the special teams so I you know
we wouldn't want without buddy there's
no question about that our defense was
the reason we won but our offense did a
pretty good job did you watch the
documentary were like do you sit there
ever watch it again or no you don't
watch it yourself no I didn't watch it I
you know you really you haven't watched
it I don't think I've ever seen it
that's the past you know we have a hard
time dealing with the day-to-day things
we deal with every day but that's the
parent and boy it was it was wonderful
man I'm so grateful for it I mean I I
couldn't be more grateful to the laying
in the Bears and and the whole thing but
that's my past know I'm no longer a part
of that I mean now and I enjoy watching
the NFL and the Bears and I still pull
for him but you know it's not the same
you know it's I guess I outgrew it I've
got a why tell you as a fan
you know and I'm not even a very spam
but as a fan kind of seeing ya I'm not
I'm in a leg guys so as a fan watching
you guys don't have a knob own la they
have something they gave up a good
player to you guys you stolen from it
right who-who else you're the good
defense on Chicago Bears you know who he
is come over here oh man what Mac yeah
of course he's a heck of a football
player is a great football you think
Rudin did alright job giving it up we
think here but what is the reason I mean
one man can't make a football team but
he can make the players around him a
hell of a lot better special I don't
want a lifetime agree agree with you but
you know if you're gonna play against
and and I agreed you don't when I'm when
the Bears got him I said boy that's a
lot to give up I watched him play he
makes everybody better that's what I'm
saying
you don't find too many people to do why
would you give them up do you know
anything we don't know like is there
anything you know that we don't know is
it everything that we've read ourself
could that's that's that's how you think
I could think his money in the money
it's not the coaches the money anyway
it's the owners money so why worry about
it
we lost the guy that could potentially
end up being loved and adored by Chicago
oh yeah this guy's give over the knee
stays here five six seven years seen as
a healthy courier this guy can have a
very nice status in this city well he
was career I was him I would want to be
in the city for my whole career and make
it my home and do all the right things
and I think he will so 85 when you were
you know when you guys did what you
didn't any were crushing it you're the
face of Chicago would you go watch
Chicago Bulls games were you following
also what Jordan was doing were you kind
of seeing his stuff we're not really it
was just more yeah you were yeah I'm
when I when I started out in Chicago I
came in 61
I knew crap about this and that but I
had a friend who was a great hockey fan
so I became a very big Chicago
Blackhawks fan and a hockey fan period
and he used to have his seats were right
behind the Hawks Anette now if people
said that's not a good seat Wow when you
sit there you know the players come up
and they hit the glass with their with a
stick oh you know Makita how all the
guys who they were just they were all
good friends we go in late and after and
nobody nobody and I'm not saying it's
out of school in those days nobody drank
beer like hockey players because they
dehydrate a little much on the ice so
okay so wait while we'd have a few beers
afterward and it was just fun I really
enjoyed being around those guys because
you know it wasn't the most heralded
sport at that time but those guys it's
so hard to do what they do on the ice
you know they're on skates first of all
and then to put out the effort they put
out and the conditioning they have to
begin to do it so 87 season starts I
think this this season of strike you
come out you beat the Giants I think
34:10 some number like that and then you
go against Tampa Bay you beat them 21 10
your to and on them boom strike takes
place right and then there's all this
controversy you know I like the new
players forget the names it's the same
guys these guys fight I like these guys
you're not a union guy okay so ya know
but that's not the question I'm asking
but the part I'm trying to say so that's
what happened then right today
it's similar things are happening today
in the NFL these guys may be going
through that again right with the game
they may go through it on collective
bargain agreement what advice do you
have you know for today if and if I was
watching right now saying hey the
players are watching right the coaches
owners GM's all these guys what can you
see them not doing that the mistakes
that was made during that time for them
to prevent well I think the game it
means so much to so many people I mean
so many people get so much out of the
game including the fans I mean you think
about the vendors I mean what what what
a game on Sunday would generate still
community it would be to me would be
silly to strike over but what I don't
know what reason would be I don't think
it would be the money I don't know what
it could be I mean I they make a lot of
money I mean I don't know everybody
can't make the most but you know
everybody that's pretty good in football
they make a lot of money it's a great
game I mean they got the other they got
the adoration of the fans I mean TV I
mean it's you know there's so much good
about it
III just to me if I was a player today
and I'm saying this I don't know because
I I probably would not
do it but I said I would play the game
as hard as I could enjoy it and and I
look forward to when the hell I got out
of it and I hope I got out one piece
what was the reason for the strike in 87
like what caused it I think it was money
wasn't it it they wanted the bigger cut
of the thing I think it came down to
that I'm damned if I do damned if I
don't who's cider can I be I'm on the
players side but you know come on you
know I you what I made playing football
so a lot of that I don't understand I
mean if you weren't playing football you
could not even approach this type of
salary I I don't know you know we look
at both sides of life probably uh
probably could have done a better job of
defending the players than I did but you
know and I said when we we had what if
we had this makeshift players and I said
I'll coach whoever we have and we'll
play and was it hard for you
well here's what happened - and we went
a couple games that really made us get
in the playoffs that year because of
what what the the whatever they call
those players did they did a good job
and a couple of them stuck with us still
plays special team stuck with us so I
mean you know if there's no right and
wrong in this guy's you know if we could
we had a perfect way to do sure I do a
different I think different I don't know
I really don't at that time you know I
felt like how the hell can you not want
to you know play football you know and
and I mean I understood me well maybe
then it can't be that big a discrepancy
in salaries guys were all making good
money and that's the only thing that
bothered me Joe would you say 85 was the
best moment for you when you guys want
it as a head coach or more as a player
63 or 85 both of them you're winning
which was was it different was it was
one better than the other I think you
know as a player
it's kind of an individual thing but
when you do it as a coach it's an
organizational thing I think that's what
I was so proud of most of all the
organization and everybody I mean you
see the pride that was you know when you
went in there and I listen to the
receptionist that hello this is you know
this is a cago bears world champ ya know
it there's so much pride involved with
and you know I thought I thought we
brought a lot of private Chicago and I'm
proud of that you know the same thing
that comes you know you know the sounds
I mean you know it comes I mean my
goodness it's still you know it's still
it's crazy
right now I mean what I'm biting my
nails for Joe but it'll be good it'll be
good
I hope so it'll be good it'd be
interesting if the Bears make a run you
know right now I think your what your
two and one yeah and they're having some
good talks about what's going on there
but you know going back to the football
side right now obviously you're hearing
about what's going on with a Kaepernick
and so when the Kaepernick situation
took place before I talk about the Nike
thing to see what you think about that
the question I want to ask you from is
this Kaepernick Neels I'm not gonna ask
you whether you agree or not cuz you've
already said publicly what do you think
about that say you're his coach and
you're the owner okay
he kneels first time he does that what
are you doing that night what are you
doing that Monday are you speaking to
the owner what should have the coaches
and the team done from the 49ers
standpoint well I would ask I would
speak to him first of all coach player
to the players time and I say why why
this is the only country in the world
that the sport is played I mean what do
you are you mad at the country are you
managed to fly who tell you're mad at
that's all just tell me who you're mad
at are there any windows you Carter in
equities yeah sure there might be
inequities but not very many so what is
it man matter who it please I mean I
don't know what you're talking about
we're a country of law and order we
always should be it always will be I
hope I'm not saying that what he did is
right wrong I think there's a better way
to express yourself I think you let down
your organization let down your
teammates that's that that's what I
think so you know I think a lot is being
put on that on him because he's a 23
year old guy okay so he sees social
media to take advantage of it so you're
saying if you were to coach you'd have a
one-on-one what do you think the owners
how much involvements in a situation
like that should an owner take or should
they at all so as an owner with the
owners typical because I don't know what
it is you've been a coach before you
talk to the owner do you say hey Hal is
hey you know this is what we're doing
doesn't say Alan
taken from him no but I know two
different legal planners in and out of
Dodge you know today's all about
corporate social responsibility so
you're asking me about how the guy would
be out of Dodge
Oh serious seriously yes would you say
that would be the case with most owners
during the eighties I I think that would
be true every day I really do yeah I
don't know that I can say that you can't
speak for everybody with Coach Alice
I've said that he would be out of Dodge
anybody got beyond and then that not
just him not that make him right or
wrong it's just that's way he you know
listens it there's got to be a you know
there's got to be a loyal to if you have
a job and somebody hires you to do the
job there's got to be a certain amount
of loyalty to those people who hire you
and the league I mean if I mean what's
what's his lorry then where's it to I
mean he said it wasn't to the country so
what the hell was it - I don't know so
you know I don't have an answer for it
but I don't agree with it all I'm trying
to figure out is here's how I'm
processing it I'm processing it saying
okay say he did what he did but the
people in leadership positions why
didn't they take the lead okay so say
you have a one-on-one conversation topic
opinion they're afraid of it that's a
problem exactly it's a problem I mean
that that's their problem okay so go to
the other one go down could Roger Roger
Goodell done in a different way should
he have handled under different what is
the involvement of a guy like him he
gets paid a quarter million dollars over
five years private jet he gets all this
other stuff right he's getting paid to
do that what is his role could he have
prevented this thing to become what it
is today
well I don't know what would he have
done I mean you're ducking him in the
Kaepernick case I'm talking about what
if Roger calls the Kaepernick and says
bring him in and they sit down said
what's your frustration what are you
doing about and then hey if this is what
it is as a corporate social
responsibility why don't we make a
statement that we're all aligned on the
same page and let's you know let's do
what we're doing as a that's the part I
see with Roger because he did it he
thought for himself at least my
processing from the outside you know
what I think this is gonna be done we're
gonna get over in six months no one's
even gonna think about it but that's not
what happened so got bigger and bigger
and bigger so could Roger have gotten
involved earlier and had a conversation
with the management
team and the ownership team and himself
to see what he's frustrated about and
then talk to the other guys Troy Vincent
maybe we can figure something out and
that wasn't done yeah you know in
retrospect say yeah I probably could
have but I don't know that I really you
know it's it's hard to me to be
sympathetic for not appreciating the
opportunities you have as a professional
athlete I just think it's special I mean
you're gifted first of all by having the
size and the body and the mind to be
able to do that stuff and then III I
don't know I but somebody has to tell me
what are you protesting I don't know I
still haven't heard that don't wouldn't
told me what he's protesting what I
don't know I just tell me what you're
protesting and then I have a better
chance of understanding the flag the
only John the only country that supports
playing is here I mean you know is it
perfect no but it beats the hell out of
about 99.9% of the other ones that
aren't you know so I don't have an
answer for it I'm just saying I I think
there's a better way to do it than what
he did it I don't know yeah the only
reason I ask is because I don't think
it's gonna stop I I think this is the I
think Kaepernick is gonna be the
beginning of many of these other issues
that's going to happen as well because
of social media you know the game is a
different game today than back then back
then Michael Jordan they asked him they
said so you know who are your customers
Republicans or Democrats he says both of
them I'm not I'm not going to take the
position politically because I'm gonna
have both but today LeBron takes a
position because of social media it's
almost as if the social media is
pressuring players to take positions
today while back then it wasn't as
critical because you guys would just
play come down you would do your press
conference you're gone you go into your
family you wouldn't be tweeting all
night and people wonder what you're
thinking about your thoughts would stay
with you yeah you're right I mean that
that you know you make a good point
there you know when you I don't have an
answer for it I really don't it's I
guess make the point I'm trying to make
is football would have been exciting
when Twitter was run if you were playing
nice that but I'm saying let's just save
Twitter was around and you got a 28 year
old Mike Ditka you know what would you
be saying I can't believe Hallas you
know with that what would an emotional
person like you so maybe somebody from
their generation maybe saying well how
do you know how he's gonna handle it he
didn't know about Twitter was you know
like even husband or wife fights
nowadays right before you got into fight
with your wife you're leaving work you
know what you're working late again I
can't believe this this is this is this
click you got a 40-minute drive home
today
click the entire drivers text text text
text text text so everything I want to
tell you I've already told you on text
rather before by the time I come home
I'm over it I've had a drink I'm calm
maybe it's gonna change it I don't know
how much of an effect social media is
having in what we're facing today well
can I tell you something I'd love to
hear it has no effect in my life because
I don't pay attention to one bit of it
I'm not on social media 0 well then what
do you mean texting texting Twitter
Facebook I'm not on that so and then no
interest no what do you think about the
guy that we call the commander-in-chief
of America who is a master Twitter guy
you know yeah that's probably why I'm
not I don't know I I I would choose to
communicate with anybody person person
you won't you want to know my opinion
ask me and I'll tell you yeah but I
don't I want to put it out there for the
world to see it cuz I'm you know it's I
don't think I'll first of all don't
think my opinion that that important you
know but I have one I mean you know the
opinion if like noses we all have one
you know time run more than others
that's all I saw your wife say in an
interview she said you know mike says
yes to everybody you know yes I let's
sit down and talk yes you know at that
time when you're coming up people you
were wanting to help out a lot of people
so business-wise you were coming out and
then some advisors were saying well you
know you may want to say no you know to
what you're saying I'm just wondering
I'm thinking knowing your way you're
wired
how would a coach Ditka be with social
media would it be any different I guess
we'll never know you know I guess we'll
never know I know I don't want to get
involved I mean I'm not criticizing the
people who social media they want to do
whatever they want to do but I mean I
thought there was a thing that you know
your life was your own why wouldn't want
to keep it private
I mean why does everybody have to know
and to me that's about a go do you want
people to know while I've done this and
I'm but who the hell cares
I don't maybe they do but I don't today
today's a different time today everybody
wants to know what you're thinking about
so for here's a question for you 404 I
think oh four yeah obviously the city
loves you they've called you a lot of
different names but they love you and
they wanted you to run for mayor one
time and I think Oh for there were some
rumors about you running for Senate did
you like did you ever have aspirations
for never so you know so this is what
people said well you never wanted run no
they yeah they tried a brought it up
running for Senate against Barack Obama
and I should know I had no desire to and
I never never really thought about it
and I don't I mean I'm not a politician
I don't profess to be but I do profess
to be a great American and I believe in
this country is it perfect nope but I
tell you what it's a lot better than
anything else I'm saying so I'm somebody
that agrees with that side myself this
is we're here now from Iran and I'm a
die-hard fan of what this country offers
and I speak about it all the time but
asking you what do you think makes this
country as special as it does well I
think first of all opportunity I don't
care who you are where you come from
nationality color creed you have a
chance to attain the highest office in
the country you can grow to anything you
can be anything you want to be you can
you look at the athletes coming in the
baseball players the Hispanic baseball
players the African Americans whites I
mean these kids I don't think they were
born with it with a silver spoon in
their mouth I mean they worked hard
they're born in the ghettos of New York
and Boston and Chicago and and and
they've risen up you know I'm amazed I
played a lot of baseball as a kid and
growing up and thought I was a pretty
good baseball player one time to watch
these guys play that sport right now wow
wow are they good are they good and I
you know my all-time hero standing
Musial one of the greatest players that
ever played the game with the Cardinals
it was made my childhood hero and their
son
200 stand users now honestly I mean not
not as the person I'll never understand
usual as a person but I mean the way
they hit the new thing it's amazing to
watch these guys and when the bass
swings I mean okay you're swinging hard
but I boggles the heck a long way so I
really enjoyed watching baseball time
we'll go home watch the Cubs do you
really enjoy watching baseball I don't
Katelin but I watch all sports god I
watch I mean if tennis was on I watch it
Ryder Cup I love golf I love to watch
that and you get countries you know
Europe in the you I mean it's a great
competition but still the thing is it's
an individual competition but it's a
team competition I can't like that Jerry
West says he has a hard time watching
basketball because Jerry was you know
the logo the NBA he is a hard time
watching basket because he sees it from
the eyes of a big game like a perfect
game like oh my gosh you missed the
screen you missed this when you watch
football are you super critical of
seeing things that you would have done
differently or is it easy for you to
watch it and enjoy the game I'm not
critical I I just don't like the
behavior of some players who act like
fools but other than that I nothing
bothers me I mean I thought a play where
the idea is going to work some of them
don't work some of them do work and you
call for reasons but I got saving one
story now you know didn't know this and
probably a lot of people don't but they
should you should know this when I was a
sophomore kid I played baseball football
and basketball and I played basketball
for Pitt and we played at West Virginia
my sophomore year and we had two kids on
a team from Kentucky and they were
pretty good players but they both filed
out so I went in in late in the second
quarter and I had a guard a guy named
Jerry West come on they asked him years
later if he remembered I said yeah he
said I was afraid I wouldn't have a pro
career what I got he was so good it was
scary I mean hey I'm a football player
I'm not a mean well
you know and but but anyways it was
interesting to the mouse when I claimed
the flame
okay guarded jerry west for two minutes
war files and probably about ten points
wow wow in your opinion who is the
greatest quarterback of all time there
is no such thing really yeah so you
don't even think you sit there and see
what these guys are doing today is
incredible but journey knife was pretty
good
you cannot tell me there's no it's
pretty good but you fella Brady's pretty
good but who's the greatest a big video
or no there is no offense Jews do you do
anything with baseball on that or not at
all right the best centerfielder you're
not gonna say Willie Mays or Griffin or
what I mean you say best left field
you're not gonna say bonds on the left
field first baseman you're not gonna
pick a name for first base or pitcher
maybe Ryan or rain are you I'm probably
not that you had a good a baseball fan
and be able to do that but I I would
whistle Willie Mays for sure let me ask
you in a different way you're putting a
football team together I'm gonna give
you positions you pick the players it's
not even the greatest quarterback who's
your quarterback pick your quarterback
well I think you know that depends I
mean there's so many good ones out there
give me one you got it you got this is
your draft pick okay we're playing
traffic yeah first big quarterback you
need a quarterback who you taking they
have to be playing right now no can be
in the past
I'd say paid Manny Wow okay running back
who would you take auto-pay hands down
without question without a question
tight end well oh well there's a lot of
them but I probably take John Mackey old
so yeah unbelievable receiver well I
play what a guy
Johnny Morris we caught 93 passes way
back the one you did settled right yeah
yeah so I think it was pretty good I
mean but I mean there's so many good
receivers I mean I I had a kid I had
what he called with speed at Dennis with
Kenyon who was just a toughest guy I
would take Dennis McKinnon I know
because I know what if I if I to his
voters earlier he was gonna make every
effort to make that catch and if I said
you know what you got to block that
safety or that linebacker he going in
box top receivers won't do that anymore
they don't that's so true because yes
right
how about linebacker well there's so
many of them you know I played with
Butkus and I don't know that anybody
played the middle linebacker position
much better but it played against
Nitschke all those years he was
fantastic I had Singletary he was kind
of a a cerebral combination of those
guys I you know I I don't know I mean I
named for him there I get but I'm gonna
gum forgetting people now you know I go
back you know I played against Chuck
Bednarik come on you know it's how far
back I go so and there were a lot of
them that could really play the game and
play the position but well Kenickie cuz
he killed me he beat me up Singletary
because III think Singletary ranks with
all the with any other all-time great
football players he seems like a leader
you seem like a guy why do you wait
captain
he wasn't even talking to him he was a
holy place class she led by example to
not by words
he seems like that guy it seems like
that guy coach if you had to pick one
coach obviously you can't pick yourself
so if you have to pick one coach well I
would never pick myself anyways I mean
well you know it would be hard to pick
because my whole career was sent around
to men I would pick those two men
coach Alice and coach Landers you would
stay there period and I mean I I had two
opportunities in life were given me that
it was up to me to make him work first
one was when he drafted me number one
was coach Alice and I made that work and
then I got traded away from the Bears
because I became a pain in the butt and
I went to Philadelphia for two years
which gave me a lot of humility and I've
actually retired from football I was
done and I got a phone call Tom Landry
said he just traded for me and it
changed my life because I went down the
Dallas got in the best shape of my life
and I became the best team football
player I ever was in Dallas Wow with the
two for the team and I really enjoyed
those years and then
then you know hired me as an assistant
coach so you know history history I mean
he called me in the day I he said he
said how do you know how you know how do
you like this coaching I said I like it
I said I've learned a lot for you and I
like it he said well I just had a call
from George Halas myself right he said I
think he wants to hire you to coach the
rears and I and I you know that was
shocking it because I never expected
that and and I and I and I look at him
and I said do you think I'm ready and he
said you're ready what was it that was
up Wow it was simple so he's so you
might have wanted to get rid of yeah we
gave you the bus yeah but he didn't and
it's such a magnificent man I really and
I had so many great years in Dallas
because of him and yeah it's the press
conference I think it's January 20th
1982 with you and Alice it's a very very
special press conference when you watch
it you can feel the emotions like first
of all your eyes in that press
conference its fire you got so much fire
behind those eyes like you want to prove
a point this is my city I'm here I'm an
opportunity I don't know what do you do
with the opportunities you have in life
sometimes we squander them sometimes we
take advantage of them but you know the
things that had to be done you know the
cover when I came here was not bare and
I've told people but what it required
was putting some other people in the
right places and we did that through the
draft and one whether people like it or
not was to get a quarterback and it was
McMahon and a lot of people didn't like
I like them you know why he was a gamer
he was able to give you whatever he had
he gave it to you you know you may you
may think he was nuts at times which I
did and he thought I was not still but
he gave you what he had and he was smart
on the football field he was really a
lot smarter than he acted or he later on
to be and he was a leader and he wanted
to win like you've got a he got a
different line I loved him and they want
to did everything he could to protect
them our line loved
those guys love them and they and that's
the main thing if you're a quarterback
you're lying better lubya coach final
thoughts here
somebody's watching this in their 20s
30s you've had a lot of different
experiences but you're your guide that's
experienced mental toughness emotional
toughness competitive edge what bubi
your final thoughts were somebody that
wants to play at the highest level in
their league well I won't tell anybody I
don't care what you you're doing and
you're coming out as a youngster and you
have ambitions and dreams of being this
or that set your goals high but if you
do that be willing to work so hard to
reach those goals
it's not gonna be easy you know with
whatever year ago somebody else gonna
probably have the same goal you got to
work hard you got to commit yourself to
it and and and and you know that means
practice doing the things staying longer
doing the things that normally when the
other guys are going on or maybe they
went out to get a beer you're sticking
around doing and that makes a difference
it really does you look at great
baseball players you think they took the
one batting practice I think they were
in there slugging a lot more you know
and that's what I really believe and
because if you're a good good hitter you
like the hit so you'd like to be in that
bad case but III III just think that the
the commitment you make you to your the
effort and the effort you put into it
are gonna be dividing factors of what
you achieve I love that well first of
all I so much enjoy the time with you
you're kidding no I'm not man I really
enjoy it on Tony run I enjoyed it I know
your wife is sitting over there as well
watching the interview making sure the
conversations we're having as I enjoyed
my time with you what do you got there
for the pholis some call it a Rolex but
yeah so but I enjoyed the time with you
really you know as a fan as a kid
growing up I'm telling you I was a fan
it's all stay kids and never grow up and
just keep enjoying it and look for the
good look for the good things in life
too many times you're looking at the
wrong thing boy I'm tired and I find
myself doing that to him I found myself
getting critical and what reason do I
have to be critical what anybody else
does that's their prerogative and that
allows you to enjoy life a little bit
more in better at it getting better well
first of all thank you for your time I
would tell you about your team
to send him a tweet we already know he
doesn't tweet so any thoughts you got
comment below if you haven't subscribe
click on the sub button take everybody
love you
bye bye